imagine this No yeah why don't you
imagine what it's like to be so rich and
disconnected that you think this is the
way you famous people can help out
instead of just using your money this
one make some people smile geez we're
gonna watch from a deal of steel today
Wonder Woman helps the Avengers he used
to
[Music]
but the closer you get
okay you imagine cap and I'll do live
over steel
[Music]
other Steve
[Music]
he's back
what they need is you everyone's useless
no man's land part 2 come on I could see
how the BBS debris can blend in with
this
[Music]
[Music]
she killed
Oh
[Music]
oh wow what a great fanfic dude that
would be perfect
that could have worked in the actual
movie yeah right yeah yeah I mean great
job on the editing here right you chose
all the right moments to make sure that
they can match well together of course
if you know the movies really well you
can obviously tell where it is but in
terms of getting lost in what you
provided it really does work for the
most part and it didn't look like you
had to do too much digital doctoring of
any kind really baby matching them into
the footage with the doctor strange
ringing thingy that looked really great
they look natural replacing some moments
with Peggy with Anna work really well
too and I like how even in this like
tiny little bit you still get a little
bit of a storyline in terms of the
connection between Captain America and
Wonder Woman
they just kind of match those worlds
together now you got this romantic
linkage between the two now they can
live happily ever after great use of
line two was when dannis licks up I
don't know yeah that was great
Alice Lee as I kept going I was getting
lost in it they knew this would be
really sweet actually something like
this happened one about Wonder Woman
saving the day entirely but just showing
up BBS style that would have been really
cool when Thor's like I knew it I've
thought of all the people Thor would
probably be like excited to jam around
maybe go visit them ascared that she can
go see new Asgard like I feel like they
would hit honor of a god yeah you know
God himself so yeah perfect we need to
bridge the gap yeah pretty bad petition
pretty sweet stuff that's all for today
folks thank you so much for being here
you guys go check out a deal of Steel
YouTube channel I've been seeing this
video getting posted and a whole bunch
of movie sites and I was like you know
what it's about time to listen to some
subs and check this video out well worth
it subscribe to a deal of Steel
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell get notified we got a
video up last but not least ascend this
with a new Raj Krishna and take it away
John ooh I awoke this morning saw a
mirage and to my delight it looked just
like Niraj Krishnan his surname strong
and mighty and there he stood before me
in his tighty whities he came with a
message in haste to relay there wasn't
much time and he couldn't stay so what
is the message I shouted aloud but it
was too late taraj was nowhere to be
found was it a dream had I have Niraj at
my bed or did he simply get lost on the
way to the head either way I wish he'd
come visit again for I can be his Barbie
and you can be my Ken is very good for
Sammy